oh
[Musique]
très heureux ministre mesdames messieurs
les parlementaires élus mesdames
messieurs les présidents d'associations
de fondations
mesdames et messieurs les responsables
des cultes mesdames messieurs chers amis
je suis très heureux d'être parmi vous
très heureux on a écrit un très très
long discours il est très sérieux je
veux vous parler avec le coeur d'abord
je suis très heureux parce que ça fait
trop longtemps que je n'étais pas revenu
ils n'étaient pas retrouvés parmi
et pour des raisons diverses et var
et sont loin de la france de l'hexagone
ou des territoires ultramarins pour
passer un moment de leur vie ont
peut-être le club alors je voulais vous
dire à toutes et tous cette bonne année
vous dire que la république ne vous
oublie pas et qu'elle compte aussi sur
vous elle ne vous oublie pas parce que
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
engagées on va continuer le vote par
internet qui était un engagement que
j'avais pris sera possible dès la
prochaine élection consulaire de 2020
dans des conditions de sécurité de
sincérité et de secret du vote
parfaitement garanties et c'est quelque
chose je sais qui est très attendu et
j'en profite pour remercier tous les
conseillers consulaires et toutes celles
et ceux qui s'engagent parce que c'est
très important
on va continuer aussi à simplifier les
procédures à faire beaucoup de deux
choses qui sont je le sais extrêmement
attendu qu'ils soient que ce soit les
démarches consulaires et visa les
centres d'appels tous les toutes les
procédures
on va continuer évidemment à accompagner
nos ressortissants partout dans le monde
pour là aussi les protéger lorsqu'ils
sont menacés par des catastrophes
naturelles ou des risques politiques
c'est le devoir de la république et nous
continuerons de le faire et puis nous
continuerons d'avancer aussi pour que
nos enfants est une bonne éducation et
j'y tiens beaucoup c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on a lancé avec les ministres des
affaires étrangères et de l'éducation
nationale une réforme en profondeur de
la ffe parce qu'on veut former de plus
en plus d'enfants et aussi faire
rayonner le français alors j'ai pas ici
être très long mais il ya tout un projet
que j'ai exposé en mars 2018 qui a
commencé en cette rentrée et on va le
faire de plus en plus et d'ici 2022 500
filière d'éducation bilingue
francophones seront labellisés et cette
réforme de l'éducation française on va
aussi la double et d'initiatives en
particulier dans la région y en a
plusieurs qui me tiennent à coeur ce
qu'on a décidé de faire qui est un fonds
pour financer toutes les écoles
justement des chrétiens d'orient ya
quatre cent mille enfants qui dans la
région après le français où sont formés
aux français par les écoles des
chrétiens d'orient et donc on va avec un
fond les aider à faire encore davantage
il ya ce qui est fait par les écoles et
lycées dont
toutes celles et ceux qui sont ici
présents je remercie leurs enseignants
et c'était ceux qui les dirigent ainsi
que leurs élèves
[Applaudissements]
bravo et puis elle pôle d'excellence
qu'on a décidé aussi à tel aviv en
particulier avec l'école marc chagall et
le lycée franco israélien mais que fait
israël qui sera un point important et va
permettre de diffuser cela est donc je
ne suis pas exhaustif mais il ya tout ce
travail qui sont portées par vaux
conseiller consulaire par vos élus de la
république vos représentants je salue
votre député par également les groupes
d'amitié qui sont ici présents à
l'assemblée au sénat et qui travaille
beaucoup et nous allons continuer mais
je voulais aussi vous dire que toutes et
tous ici
quels que soient les choix de vie
quelles que soient les histoires
familiales si vous êtes là depuis des
générations
ou que vous veniez d'arrivée ou de faire
votre à l'ia vous continuez d'être des
ambassadeurs de la france ici et c'est
extrêmement important à mes yeux c'est à
dire que vous portez nos valeurs notre
histoire nos ambitions notre voie et
c'est aussi pour ça que je compte
beaucoup sur vous
alors vous le savez je suis ici avant
tout pour la mémoire l'histoire et le
forum international
le low cost qui s'est tenue sous la
présidence du président rivlin depuis
hier et la cérémonie juste après vous
avoir vu j'irai rejoindre ayad vaisselle
et en effet c'est au saut de se souvenir
de cette mémoire que s'inscrit d'abord
et avant tout ce ce premier voyage que
j'effectue parmi vous nous étions à
l'instant à roglit avec serge et béate
klarsfeld
l'association des fils et des filles de
déportés juifs de france que nous devons
ce lieu de mémoire je veux dire merci et
à vous deux
merci infiniment
extraordinairement émouvant pour celles
et ceux qui étaient étaient là d'abord
de voir ce lieu qui est je dirais un
autre lieu par essence parce que c'est
celui de de ses enfants de ces adultes
françaises français qui sont tombés et
avoir ce mur des noms ici avant même que
le mur des noms mais est érigée à paris
et je trouve un un symbole extrêmement
fort et il a été par votre travail
patient par d'abord un devoir de justice
bien devoir de mémoire et avoir ses 80
mille noms c'est 80 mille arbres c'est
80 mille vies qui défie en quelque sorte
le crime absolu c'est je crois une
conquête que vous avez réussi avec
quelques autres absolument formidable
c'était le 18 juin 1981 et je crois que
c'est le formidable symbole aussi de ce
que collectivement nous voulons porter
qui est aussi cet esprit de résistance
et m'accompagne d'ailleurs dans ce
voyage
je veux leur rendre hommage plusieurs
élus qui ici porte le nom de leur
village les destins de leur village ou
de leur ville et qui du chambon sur
lignon à izieu aussi en passant par le
clan des mil lions d'euros
ce sont ses villes ses villages qui ont
aussi porté l'esprit de résistance
français la parole des justes ces traces
de courage qui sont aussi célébrés à yad
vashem et je crois que voilà vous avoir
tous ici et être tous ensemble c'est à
la fois savoir la part tragique de notre
histoire et sa dimension indépassable et
le travail de mémoire que nous
continuons de faire que fait la
fondation pour la mémoire de la shoah
que que fait le mémorial que font toutes
nos écoles et j'y reviendrai mais c'est
aussi savoir reconnaître la place des
justes du courage dans notre dans notre
république et je sais combien vous y
tenez toutes et tous ici parmi nous ce
matin il y avait des orphelins des
enfants cachés avec les survivants chez
raphaël israël et plusieurs autres qui
étaient avec nous et des jeunes enfants
des élèves de terminale qui nous
accompagnait ali david herman yasmine et
j'en oublie
avec leur formidable enseignante c'est à
dire qu'ils n'étaient avec le ministre
de l'éducation nationale était
extrêmement inspirante et qui depuis la
seconde travail pour comprendre
connaître et maintenant ils m'ont dit
transmettre et porter il n'y a rien dans
leur histoire familiale qui a été
traversée par lachor mais ils seront des
ambassadeurs de cette mémoire et de ce
combat au quotidien par le travail qui a
été fait par l'école par d'éducation et
je veux saluer ici le travail des
enseignants leurs engagements des
différentes fondations impliqués et puis
le travail de jacques fredj dont je veux
saluer vraiment exceptionnel engagement
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tenu je le disais je le disais être
ici à jérusalem à l'invitation du
président rivlin pour répondre à l'appel
de yad vashem à l'injonction du plus
jamais ça
je serai le 27 janvier avec les
survivants avec les fils et filles de
déportés avec les jeunes engagés dans
l'indispensable travail de mémoire au
mémorial de la shoah pour le 75e
anniversaire de la libération du camp
d'auschwitz birkenau
le premier ministre sera en pologne
quant à lui et nous serons avec
plusieurs d'entre vous qui êtes là
aujourd'hui un moment aussi important
avec le dévoilement de ce nouveau mur
des noms ce que nous allons vivre cet
après-midi et j'aurai l'occasion de le
dire est un moment extrêmement important
parce que c'est l'engagement collectif
de la communauté internationale de ne
pas oublier essayons d'imaginer ce que
celles et ceux qui sont tombés ce que
celles et ceux qui se sont échappés est
ce que nos amis qui sont encore parmi
nous et qui sont rescapés peuvent
ressentir à l'idée de voir autant de
dirigeants du monde être
la à jérusalem à yad vashem pour porter
cette mémoire et cet engagement
et ça c'est un trésor des dernières
décennies qui est le fruit se dirait
d'un travail évidemment d'historiens de
juriste mais deux militants de la vérité
exceptionnel et de combattants de chaque
jour parce que le relativisme et le
mensonge n'ont pas quitté ce monde et je
voulais dire combien nous devons à ceux
et celles qui se sont battues pour cela
je vous ai cités serge et béate mais
vous avez étaient ses prophètes de
vérité à proprement parler avec beaucoup
de courage mais tous ceux qui vous ont
accompagné suivi dans ce combat être
ceux qui vont prendre la relève je vois
beaucoup de jeunes ici c'est un combat
qui n'est jamais gagné c'est ça que nous
allons porter cet après midi à yad
vashem est ce que je tenais à vous dire
ici c'est que ma détermination à agir en
la matière est totale nous avons évoqué
la situation dans notre pays il y a
quelques jours avec rhein korcia francis
khalifa joël mergui ariel goldmann david
et eric de rothschild
je veux les remercier pour leur
engagement leur force de conviction
l'antisémitisme revient pas à ces
derniers mois non vous savez bien ces
dernières années il est là son cortège
d'intolérance de haine et je sais
combien ici toutes et tous vous êtes
déterminés à mes côtés mais je vais vous
le dire très clairement la france n'aura
pas à ce visage elle aura tous ceux de
cette foule si nombreuse si émue qui
s'est rassemblé tout le long de la rue
soufflot pour accompagner simone veil
faire famille dans sa dernière demeure
la france ce sont les visages marqués
par la peine profonde de cette
disparition et de quelques autres ce
sont ces mémoriaux c'est l'enseignement
de la shoah
c'est notre engagement à tous et toutes
mais je vais vous le dire très
clairement l'antisémitisme est là il est
là en france il est là en europe il est
dans la région où vous vivez et
l'antisémitisme
j'ai eu là aussi l'occasion de dire à
plusieurs reprises ça ne doit pas être
uniquement ni même d'abord le problème
des juifs l'antisémitisme en france
c'est d'abord et avant tout le problème
de la république
parce que l'antisémitisme fait la
quintessence le visage premier de la
haine de l'autre
à chaque fois que les démocraties se
sont affaiblies à chaque fois que des
grandes crises ont bousculé la confiance
et ont ravivé les divisions le premier
signal ce fut l'antisémitisme et ce qui
semblait enfouis tu qui peut être existé
malheureusement encore les nausées
remontée remonte à ce moment de plein
fouet notre pays toutes les démocraties
occidentales traverse une crise très
profonde
elle est économique et social elle est
morale civilisationnel c'est un doute
sur nous mêmes sur notre avenir sur
notre capacité à nous projeter
face à ce doute notre responsabilité de
construire un projet commun un futur
possible mais il est évident que jouer
sur les peurs et plus aisés et
aujourd'hui nombreux sont ceux qui
jouent dans notre pays dans nos pays sur
les peurs les confusions le relativisme
et la première peur c'est celle de
l'autre c'est pour ça que
l'antisémitisme me ravit alors il nous
faut le combattre avec force avec force
d'abord en luttant contre eux
toutes les violences et tous les
amalgames les profanations de cimetières
de mémoriaux les croix gammées sur les
portraits les insultes antisémites
asséné par des fous des aveugles les
violences sous toutes leurs formes
lutter contre les confusions
aussi quand de manière honteuse on
détourne des signes et des traces de
l'histoire sur d'autres causes en la
déformant et à l'arrco vont quand je
veux ici dénoncer tous les discours et
toutes les formes de compris de
compromission inacceptable lorsque ce
genre de confusion advienne ou lorsque
le silence se fait
en france ces violences ou ces
profanations n'ont pas leur place en
france l'utilisation de l'étoile jaune
n'a pas à être fait dans un
insupportable amalgame en france le
combat contre l'antisémitisme est
inséparable du combat contre le racisme
parce que c'est aussi le combat contre
ce qui mine la république et notre union
alors dans ce moment que nous vivons je
veux le dire très clairement cher
delphine horvilleur vous l'avait
magnifiquement dit je ferai tout pour
conjurer cette solitude des juifs de
france
si bien décrite par vous y'a pas de
solitude à voir parce que ce combat je
le disais c'est celui de la république
parce que la république a son histoire
et cette part juive de l'âme française
c'est nous c'est la france c'est la
république qui protège en son sein tous
ses enfants
alors il ya les paroles mais il doit y
avoir les actes oui et les actes doivent
suivre j'ai pris des engagements il ya
quelques mois à l'occasion du dîner
annuel du crif et ses engagements sont
mises en oeuvre 868 lieux de culte juifs
font l'objet d'une surveillance
renforcée des associations qui appelait
à la haine et à l'action violente ont
été non seulement dénoncer mais 10 août
mise hors d'état de nuire et d'autres
suivront au delà de celle que j'avais
d'ores et déjà citer des équipes
spécialisées d'enquêteurs et de
gendarmes construisent un réseau qui
couvre tout le territoire en partenariat
avec le camp des milles une structure
dédiée à la lutte contre les crimes de
haine sera créé comme j'en ai pris
l'engagement il ya quelques mois là
aussi devant les tombes profanées pour
agir sans délai contre les contenus
haineux en ligne une plateforme a été
mise en place
et dans ce combat contre la lâcheté
anonymes qui est jumeau du combat contre
la haine réel car elles sont devenues
inséparables
la proposition de loi portée par la
députée laetitia via nous donnera des
armes plus efficaces et nous évaluerons
et s'il faut aller plus loin nous irons
plus loin je sais là dessus tous les
débats qui existe et toutes les craintes
et je tiens comme chacun à la liberté
d'expression mais la liberté
d'expression ce n'est pas la propagation
de la haine la liberté d'expression ce
n'est pas la résurgence des discours de
haine des formes contemporaines
d'harcèlement protégé par l'anonymat en
ligne
nous avons mis des siècles à bâtir une
civilité républicaine la capacité à nous
aimer en ce sens
était à vivre ensemble dans nos
différences cette civilité nous sommes
en train de la laisser miner par une
prétendue liberté qui simplement une
divulgation contemporaine de la haine
nous devons là aussi nous équiper bâtir
un droit nouveau poursuivre et
sanctionner
l'assemblée nationale a adopté une
résolution qui reprend la définition de
l'antisémitisme donné par l'alliance
internationale pour la mémoire de
l'holocauste
non pas pour remettre en cause la
liberté d'expression là non plus non pas
pour museler la critique de la politique
conduite par un pays je le dis vert très
clairement hier avec le président rivlin
mais pour raffermir notre combat contre
ceux qui cachent derrière la négation
même de l'état d'israël
l'antisémitisme le plus primaire
et puis nous agissons sur l'éducation
qui est je le disais tout à l'heure
pendant 2 roglit notre plus grand espoir
notre plus grand levier
parce que la crise actuelle que nous
vivons aussi c'est notre échec
c'est ce sont 9 et 5 passes et de
n'avoir pu pas su former suffisamment
les consciences de n'avoir pas su à
prendre suffisamment à notre jeunesse
qui était advenu
et le fait que cette morsure de
l'histoire pouvait revenir et donc nous
avons à apprendre mais aussi à faire
revivre à faire toucher du doigt ce
qu'est l'histoire de la république de
notre pays et l'histoire de l'humanité
et donc pour cela l'éducation joue un
rôle essentiel le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui m'accompagne
ici est pleinement engagé les et ça
passe par une mobilisation évidemment de
tous les enseignants je salue tout à
l'heure l'enseignante qui étaient avec
nous formidable et exemplaire mais aussi
les chefs d'établissements les équipes
pédagogiques qui seront mieux formés
mieux accompagner pour réagir de façon
efficace et appropriée
d'abord en matière de formation mais
aussi pour mieux réagir face aux actes
et aux à toutes les formes de
provocation antisémite
le soutien de l'état au travail de
mémoire et d'éducation a été renforcée
dix mille élèves de plus pourront
visiter cette année le mémorial de la
shoah ce sont autant de chances
supplémentaires de faire reculer la
haine et nous poursuivrons est ce qui a
été fait en france les inaugurations que
nous avons menés encore ces derniers
temps l'engagement sur les sujets
culturels éducatifs dans laquelle
beaucoup d'entre vous être engagé en
france est essentiel à cet égard nous
continuerons le combat et c'est un
combat de chaque jour et il n'est pas
terminée nous traquerons une à une les
atteintes antisémite comme toutes les
formes de discrimination ou de racisme
les enquêtes seront menées les auteurs
retrouver
la justice sera rendue ilan sahara je
n'attends gabriel arié myriam
françois-michel yoav philippe yoann nous
pensons à vous ici aujourd'hui nous nous
battrons pour vous et je ne cite que
quelques-uns des prénoms
ceux parmi lesquels vous étiez il y a un
instant à quelques-uns qui va ciao les
je veux remercier le ministre de
l'intérieur qui m'accompagne et qui
m'accompagne parce qu'il tenait à être
parmi vous pour la cérémonie s'est tenue
tout à l'heure en leur hommage
[Applaudissements]
je pense à vos enfants et vos familles
et je veux vous dire que tout le
gouvernement est ici mobilisés et
continuera de l'être pour que cela ne
devienne plus alors je sais combien
dans ce contexte l'émotion est encore
forte
après la décision rendue par la cour
d'appel de paris sur l'assassinât de
sara lee
de là où je vous parle je ne peux vous
parler avec le coeur parce que je suis
le garant de l'indépendance de la
justice
des principes cardinaux de notre code
pénal et je dois respecter ces principes
de la république président de la
république n'a pas à commenter une
décision de justice ni après tant de la
remettre en cause
je vous dire simplement des choses très
simples la première c'est qu'un pourvoi
en cassation a été formé et constitue
une voie possible par le droit mais j'ai
reçu tant de lettres entendu tant d'émoi
vu tant de rage de colère à l'idée qu'au
fond la justice ne soit jamais fait et
nous puisse passer alors je vais vous
dire d'abord que la justice française a
reconnu le caractère antisémite de ce
crime il est reconnu et ce caractère
antisémite personne ne peut le remettre
en cause
ensuite la justice doit avoir un lieu et
je sais la demande de procès qui doit se
tenir alors il ya des rapports d'experts
et c'est la voie que la cassation suit
la question de la responsabilité pénale
l affaire des juges
la question de l'antisémitisme est celle
de la république mais ce que nous
apprend ce qui vient de se passer c'est
que même si à la fin le juge devait
décider que la responsabilité pénale
n'est pas là le besoin
deux procès lui est là le besoin que
toutes les voix s'expriment se dise et
que l'on comprenne ce qui s'est passé
pour que ce que tout un procès comporte
de réparation parce qu'il est lui même
puisse se tenir
nous en avons besoin dans la république
voilà les quelques mots que je voulais
vous dire sur ce sujet qui je le sais
vous tient à coeur et a suscité tant
d'émoi de colère d'attentes
les prochains mois seront importants à
cet égard mais pour autant ne pensez pas
une seule seconde que l'obscurité
gagnera que la violence gagnera je peux
vous le dire et je m'en porte garant ce
combat ensemble nous le mènerons et je
ne laisserai jamais la banalisation de
l'emporter l'habitude prendre place la
violence prendre le dessus
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur ce
sujet en étant parmi vous alors
évidemment c'est sur tous ces sujets si
essentiel existentielle ce pourquoi je
suis aujourd'hui à vos côtés je pourrais
vous dire beaucoup d'autres choses
malheureusement le temps presse et il
yad vashem maintenant avec un horaire
mais je voulais vous dire quelques
convictions de ce que vous faites ici et
de ce que nous portons dans la région
aussi vrai que la france la république
porte ce combat contre eux l'oubli la
bêtise la violence l'antisémitisme nous
portons aussi par le pop notre politique
internationale le rôle que nous avons
dans la région ce que une puissance d'
équilibre de médiation doit faire tout
le travail qui est le nôtre et j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir dans les
prochains mois c'est celui qui consiste
à assurer la sécurité la protection de
ceux qui sont nos amis et vous savez ô
combien je suis attaché à cet égard à la
sécurité d'israël mais dans le même
temps à n'avoir jamais une politique
d'alignement peut-être sur la voie la
plus extrême mais de vigilance sur les
équilibres qui doivent se tenir
nous luttons avec vigueur contre la
nucléarisation du régime iranien
mais je suis attaché en la matière aussi
au droit international et à la lutte
contre toute forme d escalade
je suis ici parmi vous attachés à la
sécurité d'israël mais de la même
manière attachés au respect du droit
international du respect de l'autre et
déséquilibre qui dans la région seront
d'ailleurs les seuls garants d'une paix
durable et donc c'est la voie que la
france porte dans le processus de paix
donc presque plus personne n'ose parler
considérant qu'ils ne se terminera pas
il aura une fin elle doit être heureuse
cette fin ne peut pas être la victoire
de l'un sur l'autre
c'est impossible cette fin ne se fera
que dans le respect de l'un avec l'autre
et la capacité à vivre ensemble et je
veux ici saluer aussi ce que la france
porte dans la région à travers la
protection qu'elle a à l'égard de
beaucoup de communautés en particulier
religieuse nous étions ensemble hier et
dans un face à face qui a pu parfois se
jouer ici entre deux grands monothéismes
les chrétiens joue un rôle très
important du terreau médiateur si je
puis dire et d'une capacité peut-être à
aider à faire vivre je crois en tout cas
à cette présence et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'ils y est j'ai souhaité visiter le
saint sépulcre l'esplanade des mosquées
le mur des lamentations pas parce que la
république n'aurait à voir au fond
qu'une religion au contraire la laïcité
dans la république c'est la capacité à
vivre ensemble
quelle que soit sa religion et que l'on
croit que l'on ne croit pas et donc
reconnaître la place que chaque religion
a et la place que ces trois grandes
religions on dans la région et honte en
particulier à jérusalem la voix de la
france c'est celle qui permet de
concilier ce paname c'est ce que nous a
laissé d'histoire et parfois les
conflits qu'ils créent et d'essayer de
trouver cette voie d' équilibre ce
chemin sinueux et je crois qu'il est
possible et c'est avec si je puis dire
cette conviction
cette exigence que nous continuerons
d'oeuvrer sur le plan international dans
la région
alors parfois vous me demandez plus de
faire davantage
croyez moi quand je vous dis que je ne
le fais pas je crois aussi le faire en
pensant à votre bien quelle utilité
aurait la voix de la france si elle
n'était à nouveau que celle qui s'aligne
sur le plus grand dans un moment où une
part de cette politique internationale
joue beaucoup sur l'humiliation et le
ressentiment devons garder des voix d'
équilibre qui sont les seuls qui
permettront à un moment donné le chemin
de passage toute cette histoire que nous
évoquions il ya un instant cette
histoire folle de gens qui ont pensé que
leur futur se construire est dans la
négation d'un autre il n'y aura pas plus
ici de futures qui se bâtira dans la
négation de qui que ce soit le futur se
fera dans la cohabitation de tous avec
tous ce sera aussi notre rôle d'aider
alberto
et dans ce contexte votre rôle est
extrêmement important je reviendrai je
reviendrai prochainement dans le cadre
d'un voyage bilatérales sur beaucoup de
sujets mais par votre présence vous
porter la part vibrante de ce lien
d'amitié entre israël et la france
la saison croisés france israël en 2018
s'est ouverte avec un magnifique
exposition lifetime de christian
boltanski beaucoup d'événements ont pu
ainsi voir le jour
et cette année encore la semaine de la
gastronomie française en février le
festival du film français en mars
la nuit de la philosophie en juin et
bien d'autres événements continueront de
scander ce lien cette amitié cette
meilleure compréhension
mais il ya surtout tous qu'au quotidien
vous porter par l'école l'enseignement
avec liar grâce à notre modèle éducatif
que je descendais défendez tout à
l'heure la capacité à ce que nos enfants
ici soient bien formés
mais est ce que beaucoup d'enfants quel
que soit d'ailleurs leurs origines leurs
croyances soient formés par la
république avec son aide comme artiste
comme entrepreneur comme scientifique
comme fonctionnaire ici vous porter
cette part de france qui construit cette
amitié
alors j'avais il ya quelques années
beaucoup accompagner celles et ceux qui
dans le numérique où l'entrepreneuriat
sont une part vibrante de cette relation
bilatérale et vous savez au au combien
j'y suis attaché et qu'il s'agisse des
liens avec l'institut polytechnique du
technion ou des liens entre les
communautés justement numérique de la
france et israël
nous avons encore beaucoup à faire mais
je voulais vous dire combien ce que vous
faites au quotidien ce que vous
représentez est important pour la
relation bilatérale mais important pour
la réussite ici de ce pays et pour notre
réussite car à chaque fois ce sont des
opportunités nouvelles qui sont déployés
car à chaque fois ce sont des projets
nouveaux qui sont construits une
capacité à mieux connaître
mais aussi à multiplier les échanges
commerciaux et les investissements
croisés les échanges culturels humains
académique
la france continuera d'être un grand
pays d'entrepreneuriat d'économie et
nous sommes en train de travailler pour
que les choses aillent de mieux en mieux
et nous continuerons croyez-moi de
recherche aussi de savoir et donc tout
ce que vous portez représentés nous
continuerons de le défendre de le faire
vivre de le rendre plus fort
et donc je les dis j'aurais l'occasion
de revenir pour une visite bilatérale
mais j'attends de vous que tout ce qui
est aujourd'hui développés soit encore
plus fort à cette occasion parce qu'on
ne saurait se satisfaire de l'existant
donc sur tous les sujets que j'ai
commencé à évoquer nous devons dans les
prochains mois réussir à faire encore
davantage regarder les chiffres
on doit avoir beaucoup plus encore des
changes académique de partenariats
croisés
on doit faire beaucoup plus sur le plan
économique et commercial entre nos deux
pays
les résultats sont pas au niveau de ce
qu'on devrait attendre compte tenu de
notre histoire et notre force et donc je
compte sur vous pour y oeuvrer déployer
encore plus de projets je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup d'engagés juste devant moi en
la matière mais nous devons avancer avec
force
et puis au delà de ça vous portez ici
une part symbolique aussi d'espoir c'est
ça la france
parfois les temps sont durs
l'inquiétude est là et je vous c'est au
milieu d'une région qui est bousculé par
toutes les craintes
et ce qui se passe dans le voisinage
mais notre voie est de continuer à
garder cette forme d'universel et ce
goût de l'optimisme parce qu'on ne sait
jamais ce qu'on sème à un moment et qui
prospéra et je vais vous dire que vous
pouvez clairement assumé ses identités
multiples que vous portez ici c'est
aussi ça la république française et
c'est je crois la force de ce que vous
toutes et tous porté ici avec eux avec
vigueur avec en train en israël
n'oubliez jamais que ici comme je le
disais en commençant mon propos
maintenant que je dois l'achever vous
portez un peu de la france
ça veut dire que vous portez un peu de
son exigence de ses valeurs et de ses
principes dans la région a tant besoin
mais que vous porter aussi de son
formidable goût de l'avenir capacité à
se met à faire vivre
je ne sais ce que donnera le monde
demain je sais que chacune et chacun
d'entre vous peut peut-être se met
quelque chose qu'il rendra un peu
meilleur il se finirait cette anecdote
qui m'a beaucoup touché tout à l'heure
j'étais avec chaoul qui était dans les
survivants il doit être là avec nous
d'ailleurs et qui né en pologne qui
était à auschwitz et qui était à rogla
leur quête allumé la flamme à côté de
nous avec serge il m'a dit quand la
guerre c'est terminé c'est la france qui
m'a accueillie avant que je vienne en
israël et la france m'a formidablement
accueillie ils me disent je parle
presque pas français mais j'avais
quelques mots parce que j'avais appris
chez moi en pologne les des traductions
françaises de rabii ii 3 rachid rabhi
rachid 3 khiter abbas pour cegid erding
mais se dire que un rabbin médiéval de
la ville de troyes a pu à un moment
donné se met quelque chose qui a permis
à un enfant juif polonais de saisir une
main tendue alors qu'il n'avait plus
rien et de le dire
70 ans après un républicain président de
la république française à régler
[Applaudissements]
ils ont par là je me dis que la vie est
formidablement inventive et plein
d'espoir mais je vais vous dire aussi
que rien dans ce que vous faites en
particulier ici on est innocent et
peut-être que vous serez chacune et
chacun le rachis de 3
du sérieux qui n'est pas né pensez-y à
chaque fois parce que vous vivez dans
des lieux d'histoire et sans doute un
moment où on fait l'histoire
c'est ça aussi un peu de votre place ici
alors merci à toutes et tous je suis
fier de vous et je compte sur vous vive
la république vive la france vive la mi
entre israël et la prend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
ap
[Musique]